here it is ladies and gentlemen the
moment you have all been waiting for
justice millet sentenced to 150 days in
jail
30 months of probation and here's the
best part following the sentencing he
screamed i am not suicidal and i did not
do it he's also going to have to pace
the city of chicago 120 000 in
restitution and was fined 25 000
so he's still
saying he's innocent i think his life is
basically over but
well he clearly thinks so too yeah
otherwise he wouldn't have yelled out
i'm not suicidal he thinks he's going to
get
abstained i think you're going to be
fine jesse yeah that's really sad i
don't think he's planning on like
killing himself and making it seem like
someone else did it that's insane who
would who would be trying to kill him
what kind of paranoia would lead him to
think that anyone out there is trying to
suicide him in prison now we're getting
into crazy conspiracy territory because
there was already crazy conspiracy
theories around his what he did because
at the time those two nigerian trump
supporters attacked him so he claimed
and he still asserts his innocence uh
kamala harris was advocating for this uh
lynching bill which i believe just
passed yeah it did pass yeah
yeah a lot of people were like isn't
that weird that this thing happened to
smile at the same time and he's friends
with these people ah
look i think the guy was staging a hoax
to bolster his career yes you know what
you don't need to draw a bigger
conspiracy than that you know what i
mean but for him to come out and scream
he's not suicidal when the conspiracy
was already that he was like colluding
with democrats to pass laws or whatever
which is
a bit absurd you know in and of itself
maybe he's playing that up maybe he's
trying to make people think that you
know i don't know there's a conspiracy
against him or something he strikes me
as a really really scared person yeah
you know in general yeah he can also
obviously just be completely insane i
don't know but that's just a very
bizarre response the dude's clearly
insane well i mean if you're going into
for one it's scary to go to prison right
so of course he's extremely scared and
he doesn't know what's going to happen
to him you worry about your safety when
you're going to prison but i don't know
if it has to be some super big
conspiracy of thinking oh the
government's after me or it's somebody
you know and they're going to epstein me
in prison or something i mean i think it
could just be as simple as people are
angry with him for staging a crime when
there's real racism in the world and
he's now faking it in order to get
attention it upsets people that's a good
point he might just go to jail and there
might be some guy who's like you have
set us back yeah you know how many years
with civil rights and just be like
he's not going to prison he's going to
jail so if he's in chicago i think he
might go to county over at like 26 in
california i think that's where it's at
which is really bad he's not going to go
away for that very long though 150 days
he's going to be he's going to be out
i mean how long do you think he's going
to actually serve of 150 days but of
that that felony charge he can't travel
anymore it's going to be really
difficult for him to travel
internationally so here's my
understanding about chicago i don't know
i think they'll put him in cook county
jail i think it's at 26 in california
it's on the south side my what i'm told
from all the people who are down there
you're probably going to be fine it's a
pretty bad spot but everyone's scared
because when you're there in illinois
you can only go to jail for just under
one year so 364 days if you hit 365 they
try if you have to go to prison so
prison is a year more and this is my
understanding i could be wrong about
this so for people who are at cook
county just in jail they're like hey man
i don't need trouble man i'm gonna get
out you know what i mean don't don't
don't screw around because they'll
charge you with something and then push
it longer and then send you to like
joliet or something like that
i think he's gonna be fine
i think he's gonna go to jail and he's
gonna complain about it
him screaming he's not suicidal to me
sounds more like a spoiled rich guy yeah
who doesn't know what real hardship is
and he's probably freaking out like oh
man oh they're going to kill me in
prison yeah that's fair that's probably
more yeah
some of the quotes from the judge one is
your very name has become an adverb for
lying
you were throwing a national pity party
for yourself i i didn't listen to it yet
but this is uh well he's not wrong no
well here's my question you guys 150
days in jail
too long no just too long no not for a
federal crime like this the guy i don't
think it was federal was it really
it was just like this felony a felony if
that's a felony that's a difference
that's okay federal is like when you
cross state lines into it okay no no it
was it was multiple felonies it was
definitely felonious i mean i don't care
who you are
at some point well i guess if you're the
president it's not illegal but at some
point
because it copycats will come along and
do what he did if they don't punish the
guy
i don't there's got to be another way to
punish him than just jail i mean i know
we're a society that just really loves
to incarcerate people but i just think
that there's maybe another way i mean
this guy's not a danger to anyone and we
have overcrowding in prisons we we
incarcerate everybody for everything and
i just think certain crimes when you're
not in actual danger i mean i'm not
afraid of this guy if i cross him in the
street
what is he going to do to me nothing
what is he going to do to you i mean i
understand i think he should pay for
what he's done
but i think there's maybe another way to
do it than to just incarcerate yeah he's
not physically violent of physical
violent threat but his mind is dangerous
because he got cops to waste their time
and take them away from people that
could have needed their help totally
exactly and i mean as a rich celebrity
paying a fine is it necessarily going to
be the worst thing in the world for him
this is someone who literally just
smeared half of the country by
insinuating that because they were trump
supporters they wanted to hurt him and
that it's a fact that there are just
these roving trump supporters going
around the country and democrat-run
cities like chicago trying to lynch
people at two in the morning so so how
about he gets sentenced to
uh
attending every trump rally right
something right
or like public shaming like they do in
china
here's the thing that would provide him
with so many opportunities to come up
with fake hate crime stories and the
democrats would believe every single one
they'd be like just cause he lied once
doesn't mean these other ones aren't
true there's got to be something else
though there's i'm going to agree with
you education camps for some reason i
was watching 60 days in last night this
reality show i've never heard of until
last night about people going undercover
into prison and i was like it's it's
real it's like finally i've never been
in prison and i didn't really
understand what it is until last night
i'm starting to get an idea of how stuck
together all these people are in the
higher immediate you get in and it's
like just gang warfare basically oh yeah
i don't think it's good for people like
jesse it doesn't make sense no and
there's other ways to punish people
other than right now it is just prison
or fines i mean i'm saying there are
other ways and there's other countries
that have figured out other ways and
then we would just have to have a
discussion on how moral they are why is
there anything particularly well like
china literally just did a public
shaming event where they made the people
they marched them down the street and
they had to wear
signs
and there was a parade of people looking
at them and the sign you know said what
they had done and there was yeah so
here's the thing yeah well we were
saying that's exactly what we would do
but we would have some discussion on
what would be the ethical or moral thing
to do that doesn't involve necessarily
prison or a fine you know get out of
jail free card or get out of a jail 17
years of hard labor and i would like
rocks well i mean in the united states
we have a much more uh humane method of
public humiliation where we take people
who are never given a trial and then our
media just smears them for arguing
against the narrative that's great well
that's what they argued like his defense
attorney said that he's already had his
reputation and life destroyed
he's suffering exactly and of course i'm
not trying to make light of of china
their tactics for punishment but jesse
smallett has clearly been publicly
publicly humiliated at the end of this
thing he yells out i didn't do it yeah
yeah like come on he didn't know that
that's a very good point he hasn't
accepted responsibility for the crime
yet it's hard to be sympathetic to him
right
he should go to jail until he admits
that he did it oh my gosh now we're
talking i'm absolutely joking about all
right
all you got to do is say you didn't you
can go home yeah that's fine i did it oh
you're going to present now you
confessed oh you know the thing about
jail
i think they're completely broken
sending you know you get these young men
they'll go to prison for some petty
crime or some like some relatively minor
offense but enough to warrant prison and
then they come out hardened they come
out
just mixing all of these people who are
of a criminal element
so i don't know what the answer is but i
think the reason we just do president
fines is because we have we you're not
allowed to engage the u.s cannot engage
in cruel and unusual punishment so
unusual simply means
out of the ordinary we need to have a
set system which like everybody has to
be you know abide by the same kind of
punishment
the problem i suppose is we've grown to
view prison as punishment or retribution
instead of rehabilitation
people want justice and to most people
they want you to suffer
and that's a problem you know there's a
video i watched it's crazy this guy
murders this young girl
he's in court
and he's sitting there and he's like a
serial killer and this was like a viral
video on reddit and all of these people
are yelling at him like you're a monster
and what you've done and he's just
stoned face the whole time and then
finally like this guy comes up and he's
like i forgive you for what you've done
and then the murderer just starts
bawling and crying and freaking out and
it's like
man maybe maybe we need to uh
we need to reassess as a society what
our goals are with people who break the
law so i hear what you're saying and i
place a lot of emphasis and value on
forgiveness as a christian i think it's
unbelievably important but we also can't
engage in a kind of false mercy which
refuses to punish crime because then
what happens is more people commit
crimes against innocent victims and
there's more human suffering generated
overall i don't know if that's true i
think it is yeah if there are no
criminal punishments for for crimes of
course people are going to be more
likely to commit crimes you're going to
have more innocent victims who are
harmed i mean i i agree that you have to
have punishment for a crime but i don't
know if saying well we're going to
punish you know we we're going to
criminalize the more we criminalize then
something will be you'll be deterred
from doing it because we've criminalized
it i mean we've seen evidence of that
not being the case it depends i mean
look i know a lot of people who are
afraid to go to any kind of protest
event because of the way the united
states government has come down on
people for the january 6th events even
though they hadn't even done anything
violent so people are afraid of prison
time including people who aren't doing
anything wrong or planning on doing
anything wrong i think they start off
that way i agree i think that there is a
chilling effect at first but then people
start to relax a little bit and they
figure out workarounds and then they
start doing those workarounds i think it
can happen again i mean i would argue
that prison time or the potential for
prison time is a pretty strong incentive
against committing a crime i also agree
with you that it's not perfect and it's
a very complicated system because the
united states does have a very large
share of prisoners compared to other
countries i don't exactly know what the
solution to that problem is but i i do
think punishment is not necessarily a
bad thing i got it yes compromise
between the left and the right
we abolish prisons
and prison sentences
and we abolish the atf and all gun laws
oh there you go
problem solved
no deal no deal all the criminals can
leave and i can walk around new york
city armed and that that's
a compromise
and i will say this about the prison
system one unbelievably massive glaring
problem is the how rampant sexual
assault is behind bars in many places
and how that isn't really something
that's sorted out and i think there's a
good argument to be made that knowing
that someone is likely to be sexually
assaulted in prison and then sending
them sending them there could be argued
to be a cruel and unusual punishment
it's not exactly the same because you're
not guaranteed it's going to happen but
most people are afraid of going to
prison for that specific reason i don't
know if we've ever cared about cruel and
unusual punishment when it comes to
prisons i mean for goodness sakes we
electrocuted people for a long time do
you know how barbaric that sounds i mean
just looking back who was the guy that
thought was to kill him though right
well it's yeah so that's and that we
thought for whatever reason that that
was a good idea a humane idea a moral or
ethical idea to electrocute a person to
death well look when there are other
ways to kill a person look at lethal
injection right what's what's the idea
behind lethal injections humane there i
was reading one study that said
lethal injection and maybe this is wrong
so you know i'm not an expert on this
the they give you three injections i'm
pretty sure three different drugs the
first one paralyzes you right because
the next one's excruciatingly painful
and they don't want you to show it yeah
so still you know are there any are
there any states that allow firing squad
there should be utah utah's firing squad
yeah i'm opposed to the death penalty
outright 100 so i don't you know think
any we should be killing people at all
but you know yeah part of this
conversation is like punishing cr crime
i kind of agree but then who decides
what's legal and what's not legal that's
the danger the legislative bodies of
america yeah or the executive order or
something like that and they're like now
walking on the left side of the street
is illegal and if you did it yesterday
you're you're retroactively guilty well
let's not give them ideas please thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you